Geo
Geo
it's true I am a Hulk
Jennifer Walters an attorney who has
accidentally taken in the hoax blood and
has become a She-Hulk exactly
[Music]
that's got a nice ring to it that name
better not stick there's something so
surreal and so funny about big giant six
foot seven Hulk in the courtroom it was
about putting a real human being into
these absurd situations
it's just like as cool and edgy as we
can get away with girl your ass looks
crazy right now
something that you think you knew which
is law shows
and something that you think you know
which is Marvel shows smash together
this show is so much fun it all has this
tongue-in-cheek self-referential thing
going on in the comets and she broke the
fourth wall and was super meta
I just want to make sure that you don't
think this is one of those Cameo every
week type of shows well except Bruce
and Blonsky and Wong
she spent all this time becoming a
lawyer and this idea of being a
superhero is not appealing to her
being a superhero is a trial by fire oh
I'm not a superhero I just want to be a
normal Anonymous voice
[Music]
about protect the world if not people
like you
this is expanding the definition of what
a Marvel Studios Production can be
good morning
this is a radical revolutionary show can
we get some shots please it's an
emergency